como vimos en el vídeo de solubilidad
atrás de pequeños dibujos de iones de
sodio y declaró que aparecen cuando el
cloruro de sodio se disuelve o se
disocia en el agua sabemos que el n
es decir el sodio está justo por aquí ok
y este de aquí es el cloro este de aquí
es el cloro aquí tengo el sodio y aquí
tengo el cloro así que al observarlos en
mi pequeño cerebro me pregunte cómo
puedo dibujarlos así que me percaté que
los dos están en el mismo periodo y que
el sodio es un elemento del grupo 1 es
un metal alcalino mientras que por otro
lado el cloro es un halógeno entonces el
cloro va a tener un radio atómico menor
y la lógica aquí repasando la
información que nos da la tabla
periódica es que ambos elementos tienen
sus electrones de valencia que se
encuentran en la tercera capa el sodio
tiene 11 protones agrupados en el núcleo
y está el núcleo y tiene 11 protones ok
mientras que solamente tiene un electrón
de valencia tiene 11 protones en el
centro y un electrón por aquí en la capa
de valencia esto quiere decir que la
atracción no es tan fuerte como en el
caso del cloro el cual tiene 17 protones
en su núcleo el cual tiene 17 protones
en su núcleo aunque tiene 7 electrones
de valencia tienen más electrones de
valencia
así que 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 electrones de
valencia ahora los protones van a
ejercer una atracción mayor hacia su
núcleo los protones van a ejercer una
presión mayor así que al observar la
tendencia de la tabla periódica se
esperaría que el átomo de sodio neutro
fuera mayor que el átomo del cloro
neutro ya que el cloro tiene más
protones creando presión en el centro
fue con todo esto como dibuje los iones
en él
vídeo pasado de solubilidad y dije al
disolverse en el agua se tendría un gran
john de sodio un gran john de sodio
mientras que tendríamos un pequeño jon
de cloro ok eso fue lo que dije lo cual
es completamente incorrecto pensémoslo
bien y esto me lo señaló uno de los
visitantes en el sitio el cual estaba
completamente en lo cierto y yo debí de
haberme dado cuenta antes qué pasa
cuando el guión y zas estos dos
elementos bueno pues el sodio perderá un
electrón cierto ya que le dará un
electrón al cloro entonces su
configuración electrónica quedará más
parecida a la del neón a la del neón que
tenemos aquí ya que no quedarán
electrones en la tercera capa de
valencia en el tercer nivel de energía
entonces va a quedar con un radio
atómico que será mucho más parecido al
del neón porque quedó con la segunda
capa completa me siguen así que pensará
si el ión de sodio
e incorrecto ya que el ión de sodio va a
tener un radio parecido al del neón de
hecho va a ser todavía más chico que el
del neón porque aunque tiene la misma
configuración electrónica tiene más
electrones que el león lo que quiere
decir que el ión de sodio va a ser menor
o que éste va a ser ahora millón de
sodio va a ser menor como quedó sin el
electrón en la tercera capa y el a nyon
cloruro ganó un electrón y con esto
completó la tercera capa es aquí donde
tenemos a el ión de cloro ok el cual va
a ser mayor y fue así que en el vídeo de
solubilidad tuve que intercambiar los
iones de sodio y los iones de cloro al
menos en relación a su tamaño del mismo
modo mostré cómo se disuelven en el agua
y serían atraídos hacia el oxígeno de
las moléculas del agua
algo más o menos así y el hidrógeno y
todo eso pero puedes volver a ver el
vito de solubilidad para recordar todo
lo que dije en realidad la esencia del
vídeo no es esa así que todo eso lo
puedes ver en el vídeo de solubilidad
pero consideró muy interesante apuntar
que cuando se ironizan estos átomos
neutros éstos cambian significativamente
sobre todo que cambian sus radios
atómicos en fin espero que lo encuentres
interesante